Monsieur le Directeur Général monsieur
le rapporteur général mes chers
collègues
nous avons le plaisir d'entendre ce
matin Monsieur Nicolas Dufour qui a bien
voulu être lâché par la commission des
finances de l'Assemblée nationale
et donc lâcher
libérer si tu veux vocabulaire du Sud
monsieur voilà
et donc un article en application
d'article 13 de la Constitution nous
l'entendrons en tant que candidat
proposé par le Président de la
République pour être reconduit dans les
fonctions du directeur général de BPI
France il s'agira d'ailleurs pour vous
il s'agirait d'ailleurs pour vous d'un
troisième mandat de 5 ans ce poste
puisque vous dirigez BPI France depuis
sa création en 2012 c'est ainsi votre
troisième audition devant notre
commission au titre donc de cet article
13 à Constitution
des pays France qui a le statut de
société anonyme est une banque publique
d'investissement son capital appartient
pour moitié à l'état et pour l'autre
moitié à la Caisse des Dépôts
réconciliation sa mission principale de
financer les entreprises selon
différentes mobiles mobilités pardon
pour favoriser leur développement
BPI France cible en particulier les
start-up les PME et les établissements
de taille intermédiaire votre dernière
audition pour notre commission remonte
donc au 29 avril 2020 donc au tout début
de la crise sanitaire audition au cours
de laquelle vous aviez abordé le sujet
des prêts garantis par l'état des prêts
participatifs mais également de la
situation financière de BPI France il
était donc temps que nous vous
entendions à nouveau sur ces différents
points notamment puisque
comme beaucoup d'autres actualités je
vous rappelle que cette audition est
publique est retransmise en direct sur
le site internet du Sénat en application
de la loi organique et de la loi
ordinaire du 23 juillet 2010
relative à l'application chaque collègue
merci relative à l'application du
cinquième alinéa de l'article 13 de la
Constitution cette audition sera suivie
d'un vote dans votre qui se déroulera à
bulletin secret je rappelle que les
délégations de vote ne sont pas
autorisées le dépouillement sera
effectué après le vote votre audition
par l'Assemblée nationale s'étend donc
déroulé plutôt dans la matinée et
presque j'allais dire jusqu'à midi
en vertu du cinquième alinéa de
l'article 13 de la Constitution le
président de la République ne pourrait
procéder à cette nomination si
l'addition des votes négatives exprimée
dans les deux commissions représentées
au total au moins trois cinquième des
suffrages exprimés je vous laisse la
parole pour un propos introductif puis
je donnerai la parole dans notre
collègue Thierry mignone désigné
rapporteur par notre commission pour
cette audition ce directeur vous avez la
parole
merci beaucoup monsieur le n'importe
Jerem sur un porteur mesdames et
messieurs
donc effectivement je suis devant vous
pour
vous présenter ma candidature pour un
troisième mandat
après 10 années bien nourri bien nourri
évidemment pour ceux d'entre nous qui
ont vécu
tout l'historique depuis les prémices de
la création de cette banque et les
débats du mois de décembre 2012
sur ce qu'elle devait faire ne pas faire
comment elle devait être constituée etc
donc tout ce qui était l'espérance de
l'époque
je pense que nous avons aujourd'hui un
bel outil un vrai bel outil pour le pays
qui beaucoup beaucoup plus gros que ce
qu'il était d'ailleurs à l'époque il a
pris toute sa dimension et il est à la
manœuvre sur
quantité de mission d'intérêt général
qui lui sont confiés d'ailleurs plus
encore aujourd'hui que c'était le cas au
début de l'histoire de la BPI c'est
quelque chose que peut-être que nous
n'avons pas en tête mais les années
passant de plus en plus de missions
d'intérêt général ont été confiées à
abpifrance aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce que c'est que mes pays
francophones en quelques chiffres je
pensais pas inutile peut-être arrêtez
moi si ce n'est pas le cas mais que je
vous le rappelle donc c'est une banque
elle est régulée par la Banque centrale
européenne
elle a donc tous les attributs et des
banques réguliers de la place de Paris
elle fait partie de la Fédération
bancaire française et ses collaborateurs
sont dans les opérations syndicales du
monde de la banque donc ce n'est pas une
agence c'est une banque bon cette banque
elle est très bien notée par la Banque
centrale européenne il n'y a pas de
sujets
elle est profitable
elle a
elle a engendré 2,2 milliards d'euros de
résultat net en 2021 et par avant je
vous annonce je le dirai la semaine
prochaine à la presse
un résultat net 2022 de 1,5 à peu près
1,5 milliards d'euros
ces métiers sont des métiers de crédit
évidemment de garantie des banques
françaises sur leur crédit aux
entreprises françaises les plus risquées
donc les TPE des métiers de fonds
propres directs investissement direct
indirect investissement dans des fonds
privés français
un très grand métier qu'il financement
l'innovation très actif en ce moment
puisque nous sommes opérateurs d'à peu
près 80% des flux de France 2030
un métier qui est un métier de conseil
et d'accompagnement qui est de plus en
plus important chez nous puisque nous
avons considéré depuis de nombreuses
années que les entrepreneurs non
seulement avaient besoin de capital
financier mais également de capital
humain et que l'un sur l'autre en fait
on loupait une partie importante de la
cible des missions qui nous sont
confiées notamment la rupture de la
solitude de l'entrepreneur qui est très
importante et puis nous avons également
un métier de d'accompagnement à la
création d'entreprise
qui est un métier que nous n'avions pas
au début de la BPI et qui nous a été
transféré par la Caisse des dépôts de
consignation en application d'ailleurs
du préambule de la loi de du 31 décembre
2012 simplement les choses se sont
faites pour ici nous avons enfin un
métier d'export qui est un métier très
important
faisons du crédit export nous faisons
des presses en garanties aux
exportateurs et nous sommes les
opérateurs pour le compte de l'état de
la garantie publique donc nous sommes
l'agence de crédit export de l'État tout
ça fait un bilan de 100 milliards
à comparer un bilan de 50 milliards à la
création de la Banque donc la taille du
bilan a doublé
les volumes de crédit ont
cru d'à peu près 70%,
60% le financement de l'innovation était
multiplié par 10
les investissements font propres ont été
multipliés par 4
et puis le
les métiers additionnels se sont
multipliés par rapport à ce qui était le
périmètre initial de la banque toujours
avec une ligne rouge ou un on va dire un
point GPS on va dire c'est plus simple
très simple et unique l'entreprise
l'entrepreneur on ne fait que ça donc
nous ne finissons pas des projets
d'infrastructures c'est la Caisse des
dépôts qui le fait nous ne finançons pas
l'immobilier ne sont pas une banque qui
cherche à maximiser son PNB en allant
dans tous les métiers il y a une chose
qui nous intéresse et que c'est notre
seul mandat c'est entre guillemets
potentialisé l'entrepreneur français
c'est à dire lui permettre d'être à son
bon niveau de potentiel
l'entrepreneur sachant que par ailleurs
nous pensons qu'il y a pas assez
d'entrepreneur en France donc c'est
multiplier le nombre d'entrepreneurs et
les mettre à leur niveau de potentiel
quel que soit leur taille y compris les
grands groupes évidemment donc les
entrepreneurs qu'elles entrepreneurs
hommes-femme de 7 bah c'est moi
l'expression un peu
issue du monde du dessin animé mais de 7
à 77 ans c'est-à-dire sans exclusive
du tout petit
jusqu'à stellantis
voilà donc ça nous amène à avoir un
portefeuille aujourd'hui
de fonds propres sous gestion qui
continue d'augmenter qui est le 55
milliards d'euros et qui va monter dans
la perte du plan des quatre années qui
viennent à 65 milliards d'euros
65% de ces sommes c'est de l'industrie
donc bpifrance est une très grande
banque de l'industrie s'agissons des
crédits nous avons aujourd'hui à peu
près 50 milliards d'euros d'encours de
crédit et 25% de ses encours c'est
l'industrie alors que l'industrie comme
vous le savez c'est 10 % du PIB donc
très grande banque aussi de crédit à
l'industrie et puis alors dans
l'innovation
notamment grâce à France 2030 nous
sommes maintenant à 7 milliards d'euros
par an par an
et nous avions démarré la BPI avec 700
millions par an sur les 7 milliards
d'euros évidemment vous avez 70% minimum
qui vont à l'industrie
donc le projet des fondateurs de
l'époque qui était de faire de Bepi
France une banque de la
réindustrialisation de la France ici est
accompli progressivement et on a
aujourd'hui un objet
qui est très très centré sur
l'industrie et les territoires donc nous
sommes représentés par 50 agents sur le
terrain et c'est dans les agences que
pratiquement tout se passe c'est le
réseau de BPI France qui est un peu la
sauce secrète de tout ce que nous
faisons tout ce que j'ai indiqué en
termes de boîte à outils est présent
nativement dans chacune des directions
régionales de sorte que l'entrepreneur
n'a qu'à se mettre en contact et de RC
nous qui prenons contact avec lui mais
avec sa direction régionale celle de
Montpellier celle de Toulouse celle de
La Roche-sur-Yon celle de tranche en
Champagne pour avoir tout c'est à dire
ça va depuis la garantie export jusque
au fond propre en passant par le
financement l'innovation direct
indirecte les obligations convertibles
les consultants qu'on met à sa
disposition etc
alors la
culture de l'entreprise c'est une
culture de vélocité et de
centricité client c'est
tout est construit pour que le client
puisse encore une fois s'accomplir
alors ça nous amène à livrer toutes
sortes de combat évidemment pour
simplifier les dispositifs et faire
comprendre à tout notre écosystème
administratif beaucoup qu'il faut sans
cesse se mettre à la place du client
final qui est l'entrepreneur dans le
territoire ça nous amène à avoir les
territoires dans les tripes ça c'est
tout à fait clair c'est comme ça que la
banque est construite elle est vraiment
multi régionale et elle est vraiment
bottomupe
on a créé quantité de clubs
d'entrepreneurs c'est avec eux qu'on vit
et on porte en fait leur message dans
l'état
et on le fait d'ailleurs de plus en plus
j'ai envie de dire on le fait d'ailleurs
d'autant plus que l'État lui-même se
réarme pour réindustrialiser et
redevient parfois un peu descendant on
va on va le dire
le plan stratégique de BPI France des
années qui viennent qui étaient donc
voté par le conseil d'administration de
la banque
il a un premier gros chapitre qui est
décarboné le tissu productif
il s'agit de mettre en transition 20 000
entreprises françaises
et ceci on le fait par un portable de
masse avec des crédits bien sûr mais
beaucoup de consultants des bureaux
d'études des diagnostics etc donc ça 20
000 entrepreneurs seront vus 2500 l'ont
déjà été seront vus dans les quatre
années qui viennent dans tout le
territoire par les équipes de BPI France
avec des outils qui sont financiers et
des outils de conseils que nous
construisons avec l'ADEME
le deuxième chapitre c'est la
réindustrialisation et la
réinitialisation elle se fera de trois
manières d'une part des grandes
cathédrales financées avec à chaque fois
des gros tickets publiques ça c'est
France 2030 avec le plan hydrogène 12
usines le plan batterie le plan
semi-conducteur avec les 2,5 milliards
d'euros qui vont vers l'augmentation des
capacités à Grenoble donc ça c'est les
cathédrales
ensuite il y a les PME et les ETI
innovantes industrielles dont nous
finançons l'innovation et dont nous
encourageons les ambitions
d'augmentation de capacité donc les
extensions du vin les diversifications
vers de nouveaux produits etc et puis
enfin il y a la troisième catégorie qui
sont ce qu'on appelle les start-up
industrielles c'est à dire tous ces
entrepreneurs qui sont un peu plus
jeunes souvent issus du monde de la
recherche et de la diptèque
et qui doivent passer à la production la
différence entre le deeptech et le
digital étant que la dictée qu'il faut
bien produire quelque chose
et jusqu'ici il était évident qu'on
allait produire à l'étranger il était
menacé évident qu'on allait pratiquement
toujours produire en Chine
et aujourd'hui le consensus se forme
dans cette nouvelle génération
d'entrepreneur que il est légitime de se
poser la question de réimplanter l'usine
en France
et BP France répond à ce mouvement
sociétal qui est assez profond
patriotique
avec des outils qui sont des outils de
financement fonds propres donc c'est des
fonds de capital risque industriels on
les appelle comme ça avec des outils de
financement aussi donc des prêts très
longs à 12 ans avec 3 ans de différent
de remboursement s'appelle le prêt de
nouvelles industrie et puis des outils
de conseils puisque encore une fois on
ne laisse pas l'entrepreneur seul voilà
donc
deuxième chapitre du plan stratégique de
BPI France c'est rien industrialisé en
se donnant comme objectif de faire sans
usine de plus par an que le flux naturel
sans de plus par an que le flux naturel
c'est donc ambitieux
troisième chapitre c'est la souveraineté
la souveraineté ça suppose que on
investisse en capital directement et au
travers des fonds français que nous
finançons en quantité d'entreprise qui
sont jugées nécessaires dans le dans la
durée pour que la France soit résiliente
sur le cœur de cette souveraineté c'est
la défense bien entendu mais jusqu'à la
fin les industries pharmaceutiques en
passant par quantité d'industrie donc ça
ça nous amène à déployer beaucoup de
capital ce capital nous l'avons pas
forcément puisque nous sommes pas un
fonds de pension qui recevons tous les
samedis les cotisations de ces affiliés
nous ne sommes pas non plus un fond
souverain qui reçoit les recettes son
pétrole ou de son gaz nous sommes
limités et donc pour que nous puissions
développer notre empreinte en fonds
propres en France nous levons des fonds
privés
c'est un pivot stratégique que nous
avons commencé de faire il y a quelques
années
et qui est maintenant important puisque
sur les sur les à peu près 55 milliards
d'euros que nous avons sous gestion et
il y en a 15 qui sont pour compte de
tiers
compte de tiers moitié état pays et mes
moitiés privées donc des fonds
souverains étrangers se faisant mais
également des assureurs des familiers
offices des grandes fortunes françaises
des entreprises françaises typiquement
enfin je veux pas toutes les citer mais
vous avez une partie significative du
CAC 40 qui confie des fois en gestion à
la BPI pour que nous puissions ensuite
déployer nos missions
l'investissement que nous avons fait
cette semaine dans Alstom par exemple
c'est ça il est fait au travers d'un
fond qui s'appelle le fond lac qui est
un fond de 5 milliards d'euros 5,2
milliards d'euros dans lequel BPI France
n'a mis que 1 tout le reste c'est du
privé mais le front lac il accomplit la
mission d'ancrage français
exercer par BPI France
donc voilà comment nous développons
alors
le quatrième chapitre du plan
stratégique de BPI France c'est France
2030 France 2030 54 milliards d'euros
sur les 54 il y en a 17 qui sont
attribués en direct à BPI France sous
forme d'appel à projets etc que nous
instruisons énormément travaillent avec
1000 experts indépendants mais au-delà
des 17 il y a les très gros volumes qui
financent les cathédrales dont j'ai
parlé tout à l'heure qui sont aussi
instruits et piloté géré par PPI France
donc au total les masses de capitaux
gérés par la BPI sur ce plan fondamental
pour la France sont très importantes
voilà alors il y a d'autres il y a
évidemment un chapitre export et la
semaine que nous venons de vivre avec
les chiffres catastrophiques du commerce
extérieur ne fait que nous le rappeler
donc nous avons une boîte à outils pour
l'export la garantie de crédit des prêts
aux exportateurs du crédit export etc
mais on voit bien qu'il va falloir en
faire beaucoup plus
et on voit bien aussi que tant qu'on
aura pas rien industrialisé à la France
on va pas très bien ce qu'on peut
exporter donc on est dans ce moment un
peu de Vallée de la Mort là où on n'a
pas encore rien industrialisé mais on
achète énormément de machines à
l'étranger pour pouvoir repeupler nos
usines donc ce moment est difficile ce
faisant il y a un gros chapitre export
dans le sens stratégique de BPI France
dont je dois dire malheureusement qui
bénéficie de à mon sens trop peu de
moyens trop peu de moyens parce que là
on est vraiment dans une mission
d'intérêt général dans laquelle il va
falloir mettre des moyens publics
importants voilà et puis dernier
chapitre je termine là-dessus et je
m'arrête là
chapitre sur la culture entrepreneuriale
en France puisque dans notre mission
comme d'ailleurs dans la plupart des
missions des banques de développement
mondial celle du Canada celle de Suède
c'est il y a développé l'esprit
d'entreprise en France
ça c'est très vieux dans les c'est la
mission la plupart des banques
d'ailleurs entre nous mais c'est
particulièrement celle de pays France
donc nous finançons 300 associations
d'accompagnement à la création de
l'entreprise en France dans le
territoire dans les quartiers
dans le territoire ruraux partout donc
c'est les réseaux que vous connaissez
s'appelle l'initiative France France
Active l'a dit les Boutiques de Gestion
et puis toutes les toutes les
associations affiliées à ces réseaux là
partout en France 50 000 bénévoles et
nous pensons qu'il faut très larvelement
développer cette action là et donc nous
sommes fixés un objectif qui est
on va dire
presque symbolique dans son ampleur nous
voulons doubler le nombre
d'entrepreneurs en France
nous pensons que la France est prête
pour ça
et nous identifions partout les signaux
faibles de quantité de nos concitoyens
qui aimeraient en fait se mettre à leur
compte ne serait-ce que quelques années
pas forcément toute leur vie mais être
passé par là être passé par là
nous le voyons partout partout et dans
toutes les composants de la société
française que ce soit les chercheurs les
étudiants les tout partout et donc il
faut accompagner ce mouvement là nous
pensons que la France en a besoin et
nous pensons que c'est dans notre
mission
voilà donc nous avons fait signer une
charte à tous les réseaux associatifs
français qui est la charte dite cap créa
c'était en mai dernier dans laquelle
tout le monde dit au fond nous ne nous
arrêterons pas tant que
nous n'aurons pas doublé le nombre
d'entrepreneurs en France voilà voilà où
nous en sommes sur le
projet BPI France sachant que je suis à
votre disposition évidemment sur
quand il répond sur le bilan des 10 ans
merci Monsieur directeur je vais tout de
suite donner la parole à Thierry
mignonne qui est notre rapporteur sur
cette nomination
si monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Directeur général on a on a
bien compris l'importance pour vous de
soutenir la french tech vous la soutenez
par vos actions financières en faveur de
l'innovation et des start-ups comme vous
l'avez bien rappelé quelle analyse
faites-vous des finalement du
développement de la French tech à ce
stade et
identifiez-vous des moyens de mieux la
soutenir à l'avenir
deuxième point vous êtes revenu sur
les exportations françaises et malgré
les efforts des différents acteurs on
voit bien que la balance commerciale
reste très négative comment est-ce que
BPI France compte contribuer à l'avenir
à améliorer les choses même si vous avez
donné quelques pistes déjà
et puis il est question également du
plan stratégique de BPI France pour 2022
à 2025 et vous dites de bébésifrance
qu'elle est l'un des bastions de
l'optimisme je vous cite je crois et
vous ajoutez même que le slogan BPI
France et et servir l'avenir
dans un contexte de remontée des taux de
guerre d'Ukraine d'enjeux climatiques
forts vous me voyez venir là comment
prévoyez-vous de manifester cette
optimisme dans le cadre d'un prochain
mandat et puis il y a un point qui
intéresse particulièrement nos collègues
sénateurs de nos collègues sénateurs
sont membres du comité national
d'orientation de BPI France nos
collègues Michel Canevet et Raymond de
ponts et Monge comment fonctionne cet
instant et
est-elle en mesure de jouer concrètement
son rôle
merci monsieur le rapporteur peut-être
monsieur directeur général vous voudrez
vous répondre aux quelques
interrogations de notre rapporteur bien
sûr donc la french tech nous l'avons
lancé en 2013
là aussi c'est toujours intéressant de
se souvenir comme les choses se sont
produites il y a eu cette espèce de
mouvement on a senti qu'il était
sociétal et qui était incarné d'ailleurs
par une une sorte de mini révolte qui
était celle des pigeons dont tout le
monde se souvient et
l'espèce de soutien médiatique assez
général et à montrer qu'en fait quelque
chose de profond se produisait et ce
quelque chose de profond en fait c'était
la naissance de la French tech que nous
avons incarné avec un coq rouge et
ensuite on a fait ce qu'on aime faire
c'est à dire effectivement de la grande
communication optimiste sur tout est
possible et ça a marché ça a marché la
french Tech est connue maintenant dans
le monde entier et la french tech c'est
aujourd'hui dans les fichiers de BPI
France c'est 21000 start-up c'est
considérable à l'époque
la french tech levée
à peu près un milliard d'euros
aujourd'hui 2022 la french faite a levé
14 milliards d'euros
à l'époque il y avait une licorne c'est
écrit Théo
voilà et maintenant il y en a 30 bon et
c'est pas que ça soit d'ailleurs un
indicateur que je privilégie mais enfin
le fait qu'il y a beaucoup de théitech
on va les appeler comme ça qui sont nés
qui ont plus de 250 salariés parfois 600
700 mille salariés et qui sont apparus
donc ceci va se poursuivre
maintenant on attaque une nouvelle étape
de la French Tech qui est
des très gros volumes de capitaux pour
des entreprises qui sont devenues très
grosses et qui vont aller en bourse
il ne faut pas rater cette croisée des
chemins il faut que ces entreprises
soient cotées à Paris sur onext et il
faut qu'elle puisse être
au fond accompagné par des investisseurs
patients alors même qu'elles seront
cotées on appelle ça des investisseurs
pierre d'angle cornerstone
qui vont rester longtemps au capital de
ces entreprises présents au bord de
chez Géant mais qui vont tenir la
valorisation
parce qu'il faudrait pas que on est au
fond
cet échec collectif prenant la forme
d'entreprise qui se cotent finalement le
marché ne reconnaît pas la valeur
le cours de bourse des vis et devise
même beaucoup et ensuite toutes les
autres startups qui allaient ce côté sur
Paris se disent on a compris il y a pas
de marché à Paris on va tous aux
États-Unis
on va tout ce côté au Nasdaq là-bas il
me comprendront il comprendront la
réalité de ma valeur j'aurais des
analystes financiers qui seront
m'écoutés etc ça pour moi ça serait un
drame
puisqu'on a réussi quelque chose en
disant il faut maintenant établir
la french tech sur le marché Euronext
voilà donc nous sommes très actifs sur
le sujet
alors les exportations que faire bon
j'ai déjà répondu un petit peu mais si
on savait
d'abord il faut réindustrialiser je le
répète mais ensuite je pense aussi que
il faut que tout le monde comprenne dans
les territoires à quel point c'est
devenu un devoir quasi patriotique que
d'exporter quoi il y a beaucoup beaucoup
d'entrepreneurs encore une fois qu'ils
ne le font pas
et on comprend ils ont tout à fait il
faut digitaliser il faut des carboner il
faut innover il faut réinventer il faut
il faut en plus aller à l'export c'est
vrai que c'est compliqué mais mais c'est
une nécessité parce que le déficit
commercial c'est littéralement des des
fonds propres français qui partent à
l'étranger
et le patrimoine français n'est pas
illimité donc en ce moment le patrimoine
français est en train de fondre à
hauteur sur cette ligne là 250 milliards
d'euros par an c'est gigantesque c'est
juste la patrimoine français qui part
il faudra du temps pour le reconstituer
donc il faut il faut comprendre que
c'est une cause nationale
et je suis pas sûr je suis pas sûr que
ça soit le cas pour être très fort avec
vous aujourd'hui
donc cette affaire de communication de
mobilisation de ensuite il faut les
outils
il y a un outil qui marche bien c'est la
seule chose que je puisse vous dire
c'est l'assurance prospection
qui est un très vieil outil du soutien
français à l'export cet outil marche ça
c'est établi et donc s'il y a un outil à
ne pas sacrifier budgétairement c'est
l'assurance prospection
ensuite comment rester bastion de
l'optimisme dans les temps difficiles
dans lesquels nous sommes
bon j'ai envie de vous dire on ne
changera pas
je changera pas les et d'ailleurs
honnêtement si l'économie française se
comporte finalement pas si mal en 2023
c'est parce que cette culture du tout
est possible du hardi petit un peu pour
narcole comme ça
elle est bien descendue vers le monde
entrepreneurial les entrepreneurs sont
très résilients
il est
mais les entrepreneurs et donc et donc
ils sont
en fait ils ont des difficultés c'est
certain mais quand on les interroge et
nos études sont publiques vous les
recevez et bien 2023 65 % des
entrepreneurs nous avons interrogé
disent que ils vont ils veulent recruter
et ils veulent investir alors même que
on est dans les grandes incertitudes que
chacun connaît sur le prix de
l'électricité sur la géopolitique etc
mais ils y vont quoi ils y vont donc
j'ai beaucoup d'admiration pour eux je
le dis en passant alors je peux dire
aussi en passant que ce que vous avez
voté avec le plan de relance et avec
France 2030
c'est normal que ça ait un effet le
keynésianisme de l'offre ça marche c'est
tout cet argent les entrepreneurs sont
en train de le déployer sur des projets
précis précis
et donc et donc les nos clients qui ont
reçu 200000 euros 300.000 euros 500.000
euros du plan de relance ou plus
jusqu'au très gros ils sont en train de
déployer cet argent et donc il y a une
vertu vous voyez au fond positif qui
crée qui engendre naturellement du futur
et de l'optimisme quand on permet aux
gens d'investir c'est ce qu'on fait
le CNO alors le cynod c'est pas réuni
depuis 5 ans
et il va maintenant se réunir
sachant que
Christelle Morancez a été nommé à sa
présidente donc elle va le réunir
voilà et
donc c'est une instance qui est très
utile puisque elle permet de
en tout cas le directeur général des
moyens de le réunir c'est une
institution qui s'autorrhée donc soit
elle le souhaite soit elle le souhaite
pas il se trouve que maintenant elle va
le souhaiter
car nous avons des comités régionaux
d'orientation
bien merci Monsieur général
je vais donner la parole au rapporteur
général je voudrais justement vous
interroger sur une question c'est
dans les missions de démarrage de
BPI il y avait un peu l'idée de
renforcer enfin il y avait je passais à
l'été de manière formelle ou pas enfin
il y avait l'idée de renforcer les fonds
propres des entreprises pour leur
permettre de se développer
j'ai toujours l'impression mais c'est
des visites de terrain qui me disent ça
que
ça reste difficile et puisqu'on avait
évoqué en 2020 les prêts participatifs
j'ai l'impression que c'est prêt
participatif n'avait pas connu un succès
extraordinaire est-ce que vous pouvez
nous faire un point sur cette question
des fonds des entreprises et de la
volonté des entrepreneurs de aussi de
travailler sur ce sujet à vos côtés mais
je vais donner la parole aux rapporteur
général et puis à l'ensemble nos
collègues vous répondrai à la à
l'ensemble
merci Monsieur le Directeur Monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Directeur Général
pour votre présentation j'ai
apprécié en tous les cas j'apprécie le
volontarisme qui est le vôtre
un célèbre général de l'armée française
avait comparé les chefs d'entreprise ou
pas du temps P raison peut-être pour
laquelle au moment de la crise sanitaire
vous avez par le dispositif des PGE
déclarés que vous aviez mis en place un
pont aérien du cash au bénéfice des
entreprises à ce stade
pouvez-vous nous dire
le regard que vous portez sur ce soutien
les éventuels risques m'envoi un petit
peu de fragilité ou non on avait j'avais
moi-même commis un rapport
un peu de préconisations qui a
d'ailleurs été sur certaines
recommandations repris par le
gouvernement pour faciliter la sortie
mais on voit bien que à chaque fois
c'est en dernier on attend de savoir à
nouveau repousser moi je pense qu'à
force de repousser il peut se passer des
choses et pas forcément agréable donc il
y a-t-il et à quel niveau des
difficultés de remboursement deuxième
question elle est elle reprend là aussi
un de vos chevaux de bataille vous avez
d'ailleurs commis un livre sur la
désindustrialisation
que vous considériez comme étant en voie
de résorption en France malheureusement
la crise des énergies
notamment les problèmes de compétitivité
vous vous ont fait dire récemment que
peut-être on était devant de nouvelles
périodes de difficultés notamment pour
les énergos intensifs mais je crois
savoir pas seulement et à cet égard
peut-être qu'elle levier selon vous BPI
France pourrait actionner utiliser dans
quelle perspectives et puis je vais vous
poser une question un peu Joker vous
venez de réaliser deux quinquennats vous
sollicitez si on fait une comparaison le
droit de de d'ouvrir un troisième
quinquennat
avez-vous toujours après 10 ans la même
énergie la même capacité comme les
déchets d'entrepreneurs à une remise en
cause pour tout vous dire j'entends
plutôt des signaux dans votre
présentation
qui me ferait penser que oui mais vous
empêche la paix que dans notre société
aujourd'hui on est plutôt pour des
cycles courts avec des changements et
vous l'avez vous même dit d'orientation
que soit pour les salariés pour les
entreprises pour les élus de retourner
dans le privé etc donc quel est après
demander votre état d'esprit
nous allons poursuivre pour permettre
d'avoir une vue alors vous aurez pas
d'obligation de répondre nominativement
vous aurez le droit de regrouper vos
remarques parce que sinon il va y avoir
beaucoup d'interventions vous allez vous
allez voir le sujet intéresse alors
d'abord je vais donner la parole à
Michel cadmettre puisqu'il est membre de
ce comité national d'orientation pour
lequel il a été désigné et je voudrais
pas que avant la fin de son mandat il ne
se réunissent jamais quoi en fait bon
bref Michel merci monsieur le Président
effectivement
ça ne m'occupe pas beaucoup que cette
représentation mais je dois néanmoins
remercier le directeur général de nous
avoir réunis avec les députés membres
deux fois de l'ordre ce quinquennat pour
justement faire le point à défaut de
réunion officielle de l'instant et donc
quand je rencontre dans la commission
c'est assez simple de l'activité que
j'ai exercé alors malgré cela
je pense que des pays fonctionnent assez
bien fonctionne même très bien puisqu'il
accompagne beaucoup de projets sur les
territoires et j'ai moi-même pu
constater en Bretagne que l'implantation
de
l'institution et son activité
particulièrement dynamique au service
des entreprises bretonnes donc on peut
s'en féliciter néanmoins il reste sans
doute pour notre pays des marges de
progrès alors Monsieur le Directeur
Général vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure
le fond
d'investissement par lequel vous avez pu
rentrer dans un certain nombre de de
grosses opérations comme Alstom la
semaine passée la semaine passée aussi
leur apporteur général
proposait une proposition de loi sur les
questions de l'épargne et je voulais
vous demander tout d'abord si
il n'y avait pas un moyen de mobiliser
un peu plus d'épargne pour accompagner
les entreprises puisque l'épargne est
abondante dans notre pays notamment sur
l'assurance vie euh je l'ai dit à la
tribune aussi les parcs des ménages et
deux fois supérieure
au montant de la dette de la France
c'est dire qu'il y a là de quoi
alimenter justement les projets
économiques donc c'est une première
question et puis la deuxième question
porte sur
l'actualité d'hier les 174 milliards de
déficits de la balance commerciale
française en 2022 ce qui est préoccupant
et BPI France à une action importante
pour accompagner les entreprises vous
avez évoqué
la priorité sur l'assurance prospection
effectivement et et dans votre propos
liminaire évoquait le fait qu'il fallait
des moyens supplémentaires est-ce que
est-ce que l'organisation de de du
combat pour l'export en France vous
semble en bon état de marche je veux
dire par là il y a par exemple business
France est-ce qu'il faudrait par exemple
regrouper les moyens de business France
avec
ceux de BPI France par exemple pour être
un peu plus efficient enfin
quels améliorations institutionnelle
pourrions-nous envisager pour améliorer
l'efficience de de la France à la
matière
merci Michel comme tu n'avais pas eu
l'occasion de trop t'exprimer en comité
national d'orientation tu as laissé un
peu plus de temps mais mes collègues
maintenant il va falloir être plus
synthétique et donc je donne la parole à
Sylvie vermeiller puis Jean-Michel
Arnaud
merci monsieur le Président je vais te
synthétique Monsieur le Directeur
Général j'aurais deux questions la
première vous avez dit
au tout début de votre intervention que
vous étiez d'abord une banque
et vous avez fait état des résultats
nets de BPI 2 milliards pour 2021 et un
milliard et demi 2022
j'aimerais savoir de quelle manière vos
bénéfices
permettent de
faire en sorte que tout soit construit
pour que le client puisse s'accomplir
c'est ce que vous avez dit
de quelle manière vos bénéfices
servent
l'objectif que vous êtes fixé
et puis de quelle manière vous êtes plus
concurrentiel que les autres banques à
quel taux prêtez-vous comment est-ce que
les bénéfices et la bonne gestion dont
vous nous faites pas
vous permettre d'être meilleur que les
autres banques et de quelle façon vous
avez
la performance pour pouvoir satisfaire
vos clients
merci
Sylvie Jean-Michel Arnaud puis Christian
BIAC on se Président je serai
extrêmement bref également vous avez
évoqué la présence dans le territoire de
50 agences vous avez également évoqué
fortement avec des termes
de votre volonté de dynamiser les
territoires de pouvoir accompagner les
petites entreprises en au territoire je
voudrais savoir comment vous envisagez
dans votre plan 5 ans une meilleure
articulation entre cette ambitieux macro
et la réalité dans nos territoires parce
que je le sentiment que dans des
territoires hors zone métropolitaine
significatives votre agence et méconnue
à votre travail et peut-être perçu comme
étant un travail de second rang par
rapport aux grandes banques régionales
et il me semble néanmoins que les outils
que vous développez permettrait à des
TPE de pouvoir s'inscrire à la dynamique
anthropodes que vous soulignez donc je
voudrais vraiment savoir quel est votre
stratégie territoriale pour être plus
présent en réponse à aux demandes des
TPE dans les territoires parce que dans
mon département des abusudes les
Hautes-Alpes la BPI était abonné absent
dans tous les cas
du point de vue des grands décideurs que
nous sommes et j'inclus les CCI dans
dans ces réseaux de grands décideurs
territoriaux merci merci Jean-Michel
Christian BIAC puis Thierry Cosic
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
docteur général
votre volontarisme et votre optimisme
font plaisir à entendre mais la réalité
est malheureusement encore morose avec
une balade commerciale ce n'est pas moi
qui vous la prendrez qui est quand même
préoccupante pour l'état financier du
pays
votre objectif de potentialiser
l'entreprise française vous l'avez
précisé tous les entrepreneurs même les
plus petits est intéressantes mais on
est encore dans un pays où la création
d'entreprise relève encore le parcours
d'obstacles et où je vais me permettre
de parler personnel accompagner ma fille
pour créer un genre de coiffure il
fallait qu'elle emprunte 20.000 euros
ça a été le parcours du combattant alors
que chez l'été aller chez un marchand de
voiture en concessionnaire pour acheter
une autour en un quart d'heure sur le
capot pour lui prêter 20000 euros et là
pour créer une entreprise ça a été
abominable voilà donc ça c'est la
réalité du terrain là encore les
lourdeurs administratives qui font que
la France a besoin de ce moderniser et
les banquiers de prendre un peu de
risques aux belles entreprises
je voudrais souligner un département
viticole que les héros aussi combien est
apprécié votre soutien à l'export et de
nombreux vignerons pas au cave
coopératives de notre garantie à
l'esport qui est fortement apprécié et
même si nous avons passé la période de
vœux directeur général puisque nous
sommes en février mais si vous êtes venu
en janvier que je vous ai demandé vos
vœux pour 2023 est-ce qu'il aurait
plutôt porté sur le volet administratif
pour survoler financier pour encore
améliorer l'efficacité de pays France
merci Christian Thierry Cosic puis
Vanina polygo merci merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Directeur général
je voudrais vous interroger sur
l'activité de garantie des prêts accordé
aux entreprises qui est une mission
importante de BPI France
les différents fonds de garantie
correspondants sont financés par
diverses méthodes qui peuvent parfois
apparaître complexes ou à opaque comme
vous le savez avec ma collègue Espagnac
nous mènerons un contrôle budgétaire sur
ces fonds en 2023 donc nous serons donc
amenés à auditionner BPI France je
voudrais toutefois vous interroger
aujourd'hui sur un point spécifique en
2023 ces fonds de garantie n'ont pas
fait l'objet de financement par les
crédits de la mission économique
contrairement à d'habitude
donc la question c'est qu'en sera-t-il a
priori en 2024 et une question une
seconde question
plus simple par rapport aux ressources
humaines c'est que la presse relate
plusieurs départs de cadre dirigeants de
BPI France et je voulais savoir s'il y
avait une explication commune à
l'ensemble de ces départs ou ils étaient
fortuits merci merci Thierry Vanina poli
le jeune puis Éric Bocquet
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Directeur Général donc comme pas mal de
mes collègues je vais saluer l'action de
BPI dans les territoires dans une région
industrielle comme l'aube pas mal
d'entreprises textiles ont pu moderniser
une partie de leur appareil de
production grâce à vos apports
financiers j'avais deux petites
questions brèves je souhaiterais
peut-être que vous nous fassiez un point
sur sur l'avancement du Front national
de venture industriels
où en est-on est-ce que c'est vraiment
un front de fond enfin pour l'instant on
voit pas tellement
même si on a besoin d'un tel outil
comment et quand il intervient
deuxième petit point je souhaitais aussi
que vous fassiez à notre commission des
finances une petite mise à jour sur les
modes de rémunération des équipes de la
BPI dans les dossiers d'investissement
fonds propres
et je voulais savoir aussi quels sont à
peu près les théories que vous attendez
en fait est-ce que vous êtes
complètement aligné finalement sur le
secteur privé c'est des choses qu'on lit
qu'on lit pas mal et donc je pense que
ce serait bien qu'on ait une petite mise
à jour sur sur ce point-là et enfin
dernier petit point effectivement
l'argent c'est extraordinaire
effectivement rapatrier notre chaîne de
production nos chaînes de production
c'est fondamentale il y a un facteur qui
est encore plus fondamental tout autant
c'est le temps et donc si les temps
d'instruction sont longs si les aides se
multiplient avec différentes strates et
se complexifient en fait tout ce temps
qu'on perd plus le temps qu'on perd pour
homologuer des produits en France en
Europe parce que tous les organismes
notifiés sont saturés en fait ça vient
nous faire perdre de l'argent
merci Vanina Eric Bocquet puis Vincent
capo canela
et merci monsieur le Président j'ai pas
vraiment de questions mais j'ai lu une
longue interview de vous monsieur Dufour
dans la tribune en septembre dernier je
crois que vous avez publié un ouvrage
l'an dernier sur des industrialisations
de la France je crois que ça se propose
vous avez interrogé l'argée relevé
quelques formules que vous avez eues
dans la dans l'interview qui m'ont un
peu étonné vous parlez d'incultures
économique de la France vous parlez
d'une France gagnée par la paresse de
l'histoire
vous parlez de la culture de la
responsabilité qui a fui notre pays vous
dites c'est le réel qui nous dit qu'on
ne pourra plus continuer pendant un
certain temps à rajouter de nouvelles
couches de protection alors dans la
période et la crise qu'on traverse on
sait que nos concitoyens sont à la
recherche de protection sociale
salariale etc vous parlez également
d'une France de français déconnecté du
réel
et vous dites il faut accomplir bien
davantage ces devoirs que consommer
aveuglément ces droits franchement je
trouve c'est un discours très
idéologique ça n'engage que moi mais
sincèrement je le pense vous parlez
également d'une France trop gâtée
fragilisée par le virus antique
capitaliste
et je vais terminer là-dessus et vous
dites avec du capital on fait con d'une
activité et on part en conquête de
terres inconnues c'est beau à mes yeux
il n'y a pas de modèle alternatif c'est
un discours qu'on entend aussi beaucoup
ça depuis quatre décennies ça avait lu à
fachure surnom de Tina vous en souvenez
sans doute donc voilà est-ce que ma
question est la suivante dans les
fonctions que vous occupez à ce poste là
directeur de la BPI France vous avez le
droit de penser ce que vous dites je ne
conteste à personne ce droit vous portez
ses idées mais est-ce que c'est bien
compatible avec des fonctions vous
exercez à la BPI merci
merci
Eric Vincent Kapo canela puis Patrice
jolie merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Directeur Général d'abord
merci de votre propos qui est assez
enthousiasmant vous avez repris une
bonne formule en nous disant je crois
vous citer tout est possible on a envie
d'adhérer ce discours et un peu magique
tant mieux ça nous change de la finance
cela dit vous êtes resté une banque
alors quel est votre situation
financière vous avez dit que en 2021 et
22 je crois que vous êtes nettement en
résultat positif 2020 à certains
atypique c'était pas le cas
comment vous gérez vos risques quels
sont les règles prudentielles je vois
quand même que il me semble que vos
actifs financiers ont diminué de 2
milliards valeurs du 30 juin de l'année
dernière je crois
voilà c'est pas très présent dans votre
propos cette partie qu'on comment vous
gérez cette période aussi cette période
avec quand même des risques
macroéconomiques majeurs il a une très
forte volatilité voilà j'aimerais vous
entendre sur cette partie là aussi mais
gestion des risques règle pour une
anciennes la situation financière un peu
plus
merci Vincent Patrice Joly puis Jérôme
Bacher merci monsieur le Président le
directeur général
deux questions la première concerne
l'état d'esprit en fait dans lequel se
trouve la France depuis un certain
nombre d'années et donc cet état
d'esprit expliquerait effectivement ce
désindustrialisation j'avais lu
également en son temps l'article dont le
collègue faisait référence et moi je
vous interrogerai sur la responsabilité
des dirigeants des grandes entreprises
on l'a tous en tête il y a à peu près
une quinzaine d'années les propos de
cher turruque président d'Alcatel qui
disait l'idéal pour une société en gros
je caricature peut-être ou je force un
peu le trait mais c'est une entreprise
sans salarié et je pense que les
dirigeants des grandes entreprises ont
sûrement leur part de responsabilité je
voulais savoir aujourd'hui si vous
considériez effectivement que les esprit
a changé qu'on a des charges
d'entreprise qui sont qui ont vocation
en tout cas qui souhaitent devenir de
grands industriels créateurs de richesse
et d'emploi deuxième élément
vous avez évoqué la bibli intervient sur
les territoires je parle des territoires
ruraux plutôt même d'ailleurs des
territoires non métropolitains je
voulais savoir quelle perspective
comment vous voyez rien du tout
industrialisation ou plutôt la place de
l'arrêt de la ruralité de des espaces
non métropolitains dans la
réindustrialisation du pays parce que il
y a des ressources sur les territoires
il n'y a pas toujours à la fois
l'ingénierie à la fois les capacités
financières et humaines mais il y a
potentiels à mon avis pour que pour
participer la réindustrialisation de la
France je vous remercie merci Patrice
Jérôme Bacher puis Gérard Longuet merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Directeur Général nul doute que BPI est
une réussite surtout quand on se
souvient de des prédécesseurs parfois
séparés qui avait des réussites moyennes
on pense à l'envers etc
plein de raisons
ceci est dit vous avez dû construire
assez rapidement un produit d'épargne
à partir de vos portefeuilles pour les
pour les Français est-ce que vous dire
est-ce que ce produit marche est-ce que
vous pouvez en faire plus
de compétition et la deuxième question
elle est aussi beaucoup plus macro vous
avez la chance d'être à 55 ans entre la
Caisse des dépôts et l'État est-ce que
ça fait pas évidemment je suis dans mon
rôle que vous connaissez est-ce que
c'est bien d'être 55 ans ça sera pas
mieux d'avoir 51-49 et d'avoir un seul
patron plutôt que une guiarchie voilà
qui deviendrait une dystopie
une diarrhée une dystopie bon
la hiérarchie Gérard Longuet pour
clôturer nos questions oui merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Directeur Général moi j'ai beaucoup aimé
votre interview dans la tribune il vaut
mieux savoir mieux savoir à qui on a
affaire
au moins au moins on est prévu
non ma question sera très concrète vous
vous proposez et vous le faites
d'accompagner de stimuler des créateurs
d'entreprise pour que les PME deviennent
des et les et viennent des licornes tout
ça est excellent quel rôle entendez-vous
jouer à côté de la des banques
traditionnelles de ces entreprises ne
craignez-vous pas d'être un intervenant
sinequanone dont la non intervention
entraînerait
ipso facto le retrait des banques
partenaires et donc avez-vous le
sentiment d'une responsabilité qui vous
serait imposé non pas de votre volonté
mais de la part des partenaires de la
place localement
on finit par une excellente question
elle était toute bonne mais
très clair bon Monsieur le Directeur
Général
merci à toutes et tous pour vos
questions donc
je reprends à partir de
du reportage en général
la citation les parents du temps de paix
c'est tellement ça c'est tellement
exactement ça donc le PGE bilan nous
sommes toujours sur une sinistralité
faible
nous avions dit qu'elle serait comprise
entre 3 et 8% nous sommes à 5 elle monte
lentement mais vraiment très lentement
nous avons nous gérons à la BPI
à peu près 700 000 lignes de garanties
autour du PGE et nous avons 2500
demandes de garantie de levée de
garantie par mois sur des toutes petites
TPE donc des volumes des volumes
extrêmement faibles
donc l'économie française elle tient
incontestablement c'est les commentaires
qu'on a pu faire tout à l'heure pour
l'instant nous attendons une montée du
risque sur le PGE bien entendu
simplement rien ne permet d'indiquer que
on irait au-delà de ce qui est de ce qui
a été estimé par nous très tôt par la
Banque de France aussi et par les
grandes banques françaises j'ai entendu
la BNP il y a pas très longtemps au
dessus de 8%
donc ta manière dont l'état Bercy a
budgéter le coût du PGE me paraît tout à
fait tout à fait pertinente
si je peux me lever au dessus de ma
condition alors
la désindustrialisation oui l'industrie
s'est plastique en fait c'est une
histoire qui n'est jamais terminée donc
les c'est de la navigation par gros
temps toujours donc la météo elle ne
peut pas être bleue tout le temps et
elle sera elle sera compliquée et la
météo de la réindustrialisation elle
sera de toute façon compliquée pour nous
comme pour tout le monde c'est-à-dire
qu'il faut pas imaginer que c'est plus
simple pour les Espagnols pour les
Italiens ou pour les Danois ou pour les
Suédois etc donc il faut juste toujours
se comparer et tenter d'avoir la
meilleure boîte à outils un mental
d'acier et une administration
aussi proche que possible des
préoccupations des entrepreneurs et donc
pas une administration gendarme je le
dis en passant ce qui est plutôt le
défaut de la France par rapport à ses
voisins même si elle a immense qualité
je ne le nie pas mais dans les
territoires si on veut faire monter des
usines il y aura des sujets de délai on
l'a dit tout à l'heure
il y aura des sujets de
d'accompagnement par les collectivités
locales j'ai pu dire que la
réindustrialisation soit c'était un
contrat social une espèce d'air du temps
où tout le monde veut le faire soit on
n'y arriverait pas
parce que l'industrie c'est toujours à
la fois là géographie l'industrie celtes
et c'est une culture donc soit c'est
vraiment très profond dans la société
française et on va y arriver soit c'est
quelque chose qui paraît encore à nos
concitoyens dictés par d'autres
avec de considérable résistance et on
n'y arrivera pas voilà moi je pense
que le consensus national autour du
produit en France il s'est reformé
et ça fait ça fait partie des rares
consensus qui unifie toute la société
française donc je pense que les
conditions sont réunies pour que le
contrat social favorable à l'industrie
soit là mais il va falloir il va falloir
le
l'entretenir comment souffle dans le feu
alors la question totalement légitime du
est-ce que vous avez encore la niaque
Monsieur le Directeur
alors je vous cache pas que je me suis
posé la question de savoir si j'avais
encore la niaque avant de proposer au
président de la République c'est
peut-être en septembre dernier de
poursuivre mon action en fait la raison
pour laquelle
je vous cache pas que il y avait toutes
sortes d'autres possibilités pour moi et
je ne les ai pas saisis parce que je
considérais qu'il y avait rien de plus
beau que le mandat qui m'est confié là
c'est simple je retrouve que rien n'est
plus motivant que d'être au service de
son pays
l'entreprise que je dirige elle est
conduite à un train d'enfer donc c'est
très difficile pour un dirigeant comme
moi de proposer à ses collaborateurs et
à ses actionnaires qui d'ailleurs le
vote en conseil d'administration des
plans ultra ambitieux et de et de gérer
votre votre
vos collègues vos camarades
comme sur le champ de bataille
et de dire ah ben
je m'en vais
c'est pas si juste ça n'est pas moi et
donc je considère que je suis au milieu
du combat en pleine bataille donc c'est
pour ça que je demande à continuer c'est
tout
et
comment mobiliser plus des
donc nous nous sommes posés la question
alors pour moi la question elle se pose
dans différentes catégories qui sont
différentes les unes des autres il y a
le volume d'épargne disponible pour
pouvoir faire le bon volume de crédit et
le bon volume de fonds propres
le bon volume de crédit il est là il y a
pas de crédit de crunch en France
aujourd'hui mais pays France et les
banques privées travaillent ensemble on
est toujours co-financeurs et puis
France n'est jamais seul un jamais
il est vrai que les banques privées
viennent souvent nous chercher pour
terminer les poules elles prennent les
collatéraux et nous faisons des prêts
sans garanties c'est comme ça qu'on
s'emboîte
beaucoup donc il n'y a pas de crédit
crunch le système bancaire français il a
fonctionné il fonctionne aujourd'hui il
y a un petit resserrement mais
extrêmement léger ça va
est-ce qu'il y a un manque de fonds
propres en réalité aujourd'hui pour les
PME des territoires
je ne pense pas qu'on puisse dire qu'à
un manque de fonds propres il y a
maintenant toute une infrastructure de
fond régionaux qui a été bien financé
et je pense qu'une entreprise normale
avec des bons résultats un peu
difficilement dire qu'elle trouve pas de
fonds propres
dans le secteur mature en revanche dans
la tech on va manquer
on va manquer dans la tech parce que la
tech va devoir et dans la
réindustrialisation donc dans les
start-up industrielles on va manquer
c'est un peu mon inquiétude du moment en
effet quand vous voulez faire monter une
nouvelle usine
je sais pas moi de micro LED ou ses
usines qui fabriquent de l'alimentation
animale à base d'insectes Amiens
c'est des montants de capitaux très
importants très très important qui va
falloir mobiliser et les fonds
d'investissement privé sont pas encore
totalement prêts à mettre ces sommes là
alors
des petites commerciales
fusion business France de pays France
c'était ça votre question c'est quelque
chose qui a été évoqué au début du
premier mandat du Président de la
République
avant qu'il ne soit élu d'ailleurs qui
remontait des émissions et moi j'ai dit
je ne le souhaite pas
je ne le souhaite pas parce que
nous sommes sur des cultures très très
différentes et
puis par ailleurs qui trompe en brasse
ma lettre au fond pour résumer moi je
trouve que business France travaille
très bien le nouveau directeur général
Laurent Saint-Martin ancien de la BPI je
dis à le souligner on va travailler très
bien avec lui business France délègue
dans notre direction régionale
45 personnes à plein temps depuis 10 ans
maintenant et qui sont nos chargés
d'affaires internationaux donc au fond
ça marche pas mal cette affaire
et c'est pas vraiment en changeant
l'organisation que on réglera le
problème du commerce extérieur français
voyez-vous c'est il y a un énorme
problème culturel
et puis il y a un problème de
désindustrialisation alors
oui question parfaitement juste et
légitime comment les bénéfices de la BPI
permettent de soutenir la cause la
grande cause en fait au fond est-ce
qu'on est une banque comme les autres
les bénéfices de la VPI remontent à nos
actionnaires avec un taux de de
versement de dividendes qui est de 30%
donc on remonte de gros dividendes et
d'ailleurs souvent il nous est demandé
de remonter des dividendes
exceptionnelles en plus c'est évidentes
pour ce qui est des dividendes versés à
l'État sont recyclés dans le financement
des fonds de garantie de BPI France qui
permettent de financer la garantie des
petits crédits des banques françaises et
de financer les presse en garanties de
la BPI tout ceci se fait au travers de
l'épique voilà
les dividendes qui remontent à la caisse
sont moins recyclés mais le sont un peu
puisque la caisse nous aide à financer
nos programmes entrepreneuriat dans les
territoires la caisse a investi dans nos
fonds touristes
la caisse a été assez présente pendant
la crise du covid en donnant à BPI
France un certain nombre de moyens pour
exercer ses missions
voilà donc je pense que ça fonctionne
est-ce que on est une banque comme les
autres puisque après tout si on fait si
on fait des bénéfices c'est probablement
qu'on ait une banque comme les autres il
faut juste que je vous explique d'où
viennent ces bénéfices un milliard et
demi 2022 vous avez 500 millions qui
vient de STMicroelectronics
que nous conseillons que nous
consolidons par équivalence puisque nous
sommes actionnaires stratégiques 14% de
long terme nous avons une influence
notable donc nous consolidons pas
équivalence 500 millions le milliard qui
reste
800 millions c'est
[Musique]
un positif qui vient notre activité
d'investissement nous vendons avec de la
plus-value
le sous-jacent notre portefeuille verse
des dividendes donc c'est des dividendes
de nos participations les obligations
converties vertes des intérêts et puis
par ailleurs la valeur du portefeuille
monte
voilà et donc et donc ça c'est la preuve
que parle par les fonds propres on peut
exercer une mission parlent de
souveraineté d'ancrage dans les
territoires de développement des
entreprises
de manière tout à fait profitable alors
ça suppose qu'on soit sélectif dans nos
investissements est-ce que on est sur
des terribles marchés en fait non
depuis le début de la BPI nous avons un
taux de création de valeur moyen de 7%
par an
les grands fonds privés
vont chercher du 15
donc 7 c'est bien mais c'est pas les
c'est pas ce qu'attend de les financeurs
de BlackRock par exemple
toutes les philosophes de BlackRock ne
financeront jamais la BPI
mais cette c'est pas c'est pas un et 7
par parenthèse ça permet à la BPI de
constituer aussi des fonds propres et de
grandir et d'asseoir en fait sa solidité
je pense maintenant est importante pour
les entrepreneurs pour lesquels nous
sommes une sorte de tiers de confiance
de long terme
alors ensuite il y avait une question
sur
de monsieur le sénateur des Hautes-Alpes
j'aime beaucoup les hautes parce que
j'ai commencé ma carrière comme sous
préfet de Briançon voyez-vous
et donc et donc je crois me souvenir
qu'il y a pas énormément de PME dans les
Hautes-Alpes voilà et BPI France c'est
des PME les TPE c'est les banques
privées garantie par nous donc vous nous
voyez pas
c'est normal vous voyez les banques et
mais ce que vous peut-être ne savez pas
c'est que dans un grand nombre de cas le
crédit qui est fait au coiffeur de
qui s'installe à la Briançon il est
garanti par nous il garantie
automatiquement cette banque appuie sur
un bouton c'est un extranet c'est
informatique on réinstruit pas c'est
automatique on fait 10 milliards d'euros
de crédit comme ça par an garanti par
nous
ça c'est financé par ce qui s'appelait
la ligne 134 du budget de l'État qui est
disparu il faudra qu'on trouve une
solution
la garantie c'est fondamentale c'était
la sofarisse avant ça avait été créé par
Jacques Delors vous souvenez 82 c'est
une infrastructure française mais c'est
normal que vous ne voyez pas
ensuite donc
ça reste abominable de créer une
entreprise
c'est
terrible d'entendre ça en fait parce que
donc moi je vais me replonger dans le
sujet parce que j'avais le sentiment
notamment dans les classements français
par rapport à l'étranger qu'on avait
fait d'énormes progrès
donc alors c'est vrai qu'on peut pas
comparer avec le crédit automobile parce
que le crédit automobile vous avez un
collatéral immédiat qui est votre
véhicule donc c'est facile de prêter 20
000 sur une voiture qui vaut 20000 vous
savez qu'en fait vous avez de quoi vous
remboursez quand vous êtes banquier
quand vous créez votre entreprise
le premier prêt de 20000 c'est sûr que
quand il y a rien c'est compliqué mais
je suis d'accord avec vous monsieur le
sénateur que
quand vous créez une entreprise tech
une start-up on vous fait plus confiance
que quand vous créez une entreprise non
tech
un petit bouclar on va pas vous on va
pas vous faire une subvention de 20000
euros une start-up tech vous avez la
bourse French tech 30000 euros
donc il y a un petit sujet là quand même
c'est à dire que quand ça brille il y a
un soutien public et quand ça brille pas
c'est votre salon de coiffure il y en
avait pas c'est plus difficile alors il
y a les frais d'honneur près d'honneur
on va en faire 40000 en 2023 c'est des
prêts à taux zéro aujourd'hui les taux
sont très élevés donc quand on fait taux
zéro ça coûte quand même beaucoup
d'argent et les prêts d'honneur sont la
solution pour les créateurs d'entreprise
non TEC il faut faire savoir très
largement d'ailleurs que ces frais
d'honneur existent financés par la par
la BPI
donc ensuite il y avait la question qui
écosique précisément sur le financement
de la garantie en 2020 à partir de 2024
et sur les années suivantes bon ben là
je suis obligé d'être
transparent avec la présentation
nationale dans le PMT de l'État il y a
zéro
donc il va falloir trouver une solution
d'ici l'automne
pour pérenniser la garantie de BPI
France et les presse en garanties nous
en font quand même 5 milliards nous sont
similaires de pendant 10 milliards de
crédits privés garantis par nous
plus 5 milliards de crédits directs de
BPI France sans garanties donc c'est
quand même massif il faut 400 millions
par an
très précisément 300 millions pour 2024
et 400 millions à partir 2025
alors vous allez poser une question sur
les départs
alors oui dans mon comité exécutif j'ai
eu 4 départs il se trouve qu'ici il
s'était pas parlé les uns les autres ça
s'est fait à peu près au même moment
je suis assez fier d'eux à dire vrai il
y en a un qui était là depuis 17 ans et
qui devient entrepreneur il y en a un
autre qui était là depuis 14 ans et qui
devient entrepreneur
voilà donc les quatre ont été remplacés
de d'entre eux par leur adjoints
promotions internes et les deux autres
enfin trois d'ailleurs trois et la
quatrième par un recrutement externe
voilà donc ça c'est la vie des
entreprises
ensuite il y avait la question de Madame
Paoli
donc je ne sais pas si vous souhaitez
que je réponde sachant qu'elle est
partie ou je serai en PV d'accord donc
elle posait la question du fnvi le fnvi
c'est le fondational de venger
industriel c'est l'équivalent du FNA qui
était le Fond national d'amorçage pour
cette nouvelle classe d'actifs qui est
le capitaliste dans l'industrie puisque
l'industrie jusqu'ici on demandait à
l'entrepreneur de faire ses preuves
avant de recevoir des capitaux
l'entrepreneur c'est ce qu'on disait je
l'obscinateur à l'instant de la tech
c'est l'inverse on lui met énormément de
capital pour lui permettre de décoller
très vite et donc le fnvi consiste à
dire on va faire la même chose dans
l'industrie que dans le digital
le fnvi est en train de voir le jour
donc ça a pris un peu de temps c'est ça
se passe pas du tout à la BPI ça se
passe à rue de Babylone
mais bon c'est fait le FNV le règlement
est signé et donc on va pouvoir
commencer à le déployer
vous pourrez le dire la sénatrice
elle demande une mise à jour sur le mode
de rémunération des investisseurs chez
BPI France participation je pense que sa
question était y a-t-il du carré
d'intéresses à l'abpi il n'y a pas de
carré d'intéresses à la BPI donc ensuite
on peut se poser la question de savoir
comment on arrive à tenir la plus grosse
maison de Private ecouties françaises
très largement chassé quand même alors
que il y a pas de Carry lintestre bon
ben la réponse est que on y arrive
précisément par la
ferveur j'ai envie de dire l'esprit de
mission l'aventure la quantité de
responsabilité les volumes de capitaux
le fait que bébé France a l'ensemble du
dealflow français qui qui vient à nous
donc c'est absolument passionnant pour
les jeunes et d'ailleurs nous sommes
très fiers cette année en 2022 je sais
pas si vous avez vu ça mais que d'être
classé 8e sur le top 25 des entreprises
préférées des salariés français
elle a fait une remarque sur le temps
elle a totalement raison
elle a totalement raison tout ce temps
tout ce temps en fait normatif
le temps de dossier on va dire c'est de
l'argent qui fuit et qui s'évapore elle
a tout à fait raison et donc dans notre
beau pays je pense qu'on est tous
d'accord pour dire qu'on est dans un
combat permanent contre la
proliférale la prolifération
documentaire
administrative
qui est quand même le sport national et
c'est un des combats absolument
quotidien je peux vous dire de la BPI et
je sais que tout le monde est d'accord
là-dessus mais la vérité c'est que c'est
quand même
une pompe à énergie qui est tout à fait
tout à fait tout à fait terrible il faut
se mettre à la place de l'entrepreneur
c'est
c'est vraiment notre défaut national il
faut qu'on il faut qu'on le travaille
alors Monsieur Bocquet oui vous avez
tout à fait raison de citer cette
interview
je vais vous je vais être transparent
avec vous
j'ai sorti ce livre
il y a eu quantité de réaction
intéressante d'ailleurs et il a
déclenché un débat j'ai fait cette
interview en juillet avant de partir en
vacances
en août je suis rentré et puis
d'ailleurs c'est une vue je n'avais pas
du tout souhaité c'est un c'est un Denis
Lafay un peu un chercheur entrepreneur
journaliste qui est venu me voir et puis
il m'a emmené bien
et en rentrant de vacances je l'ai relu
et je me suis dit
parce que je la sors
pour les raisons que vous avez indiqué
est-ce que c'est bien mon rôle
et puis j'ai pris deux trois conseils et
je me suis dit bon allez oui si je vais
le faire
parce qu'après tout
c'est pas plus mal que j'en sache que je
pense
pourquoi est-ce que je pense tout ça je
sur la même question c'est de quelle
promontoire on parle quand on dit ça et
ça permet de vous dire au fond d'où je
viens dans ma réflexion toute cette
réflexion elle vient des années pour moi
hyper formatrice ou je travaillais pour
Pierre Bérégovoy et j'étais directeur
adjoint du cabinet de René Delattre
aux affaires sociales j'étais
responsable du financement de la
sécurité sociale donc j'ai fait le grand
plan de l'automne 92 automne 92 c'était
le moment le plus dur jamais vécu par la
sécu depuis 45 à cause de la guerre du
Golfe nous avions un déficit qui se
creusait de
milliards de francs à l'époque par mois
et c'était et tout le monde et c'était
l'époque où tout le monde était
terrorisé par un déficit de la Sécurité
sociale
époque évolue
voilà mais c'est ce que j'ai voulu dire
dans cet article c'est que je trouve
inquiétant que cette époque soit révolue
aurait voulu pour tout le monde et en
particulier pour les Français à l'époque
92 on n'en dormait pas la nuit il
fallait équilibrer la sécu parce que la
sécu c'était le patrimoine des gens
et puis Pierre Bérégovoy je me souviens
il ne pensait qu'à ça et Renette aussi
et quand je dis on a perdu cette sagesse
c'est ça que je veux dire la sagesse de
on respecte l'État providence elle a été
un peu perdue en effet je le pense et
c'est ce que pense il se trouve c'est là
où les choses se rassemblent c'est ce
que pensent les entrepreneurs
le mot sagesse d'ailleurs c'est pas moi
qui l'ai inventé c'est dans un dialogue
que j'ai eu avec un des entrepreneurs
cités dans mon livre ou à la fin je lui
dis mais qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui a
changé et il me dit la sagesse et je me
suis dit au fond il a pas tort
alors ensuite
oui c'était votre question sur comment
est-ce qu'on gère la situation
financière donc ça c'est notre métier
donc je peux vous dire que on a un
risque qui est très faible comme toutes
les banques françaises notre risque
avéré c'est-à-dire les vrais paumes 140
millions d'euros en 2022
sur les crédits et nous avons budgété
pour 2023
la possibilité d'un
rebond du risque parce que le risque est
très faible en moyenne historique nous
avons budgété 250 millions donc 100
millions de plus mais vous voyez que
pour que pour une banque qui a
au fond 100 milliard de bilan et qui
gère en plus un orbilant énorme qui est
le PGE et l'assurance crédit on gère 300
milliards
240 millions d'euros de de risques
avérés budgétaires c'est quand même
c'est quand même encore très très faible
ça dit la seule et la solidité de
l'économie française aujourd'hui
et puis pour terminer c'est la question
de Patrice Joly donc est-ce que l'état
d'esprit fablesse a changé oui je pense
c'est ce que j'ai tout à l'heure je
pense que le consensus national sur il
faut qu'on produise en France il est il
remonte là il revient
vous n'y croyez pas
pardon
est-ce que
moi je le sens moi je le sens venir
alors il faut pas être il faut pas
surprendre non plus il faut pas dire aux
Français on va relocaliser c'est pas
vrai ce qui est parti est parti peu de
choses reviendront en revanche encore
une fois l'industrie ça serait un vent
de tout le temps et là l'industrie qui
est en train de se réinventer celle là
le pourquoi pas la France cette question
se pose à chaque fois
faisons ce qu'il faut pour que la
réponse soit oui
enfin dernière question c'était la place
de la ruralité dans la
réindustrialisation
l'industrie c'est le rural
alors c'est l'inverse en fait c'est à
dire que la question se pose de savoir
quand même comment mettre de l'industrie
dans les métropoles parce que vous avez
quantité d'ingénieurs qui ne veulent pas
aller travailler dans le rural c'est
bien notre problème on a un énorme
problème humain et donc la question que
pose les patrons de métropole c'est
comment je réindustrialise chez moi pour
pour
convaincre les ingénieurs de mes écoles
métropolitaines l'école de Troie l'école
de Châlons-en-Champagne l'école de je
sais pas quoi de rester dans le
territoire
dans l'industrie et de pas aller dans le
conseil ou dans la finance ou etc donc
il faut qu'on fasse les deux il faut
qu'on fasse remonter les usines dans les
friches qui sont dans la ruralité les
friches sont dans la réalité ne sont pas
dans les métropoles
et il faut qu'on fasse par ailleurs
monter de l'industrie dans les zones
métropolitaines pour faire les deux
alors Jérôme
Bacher B donc nos produits de retail
on en a fait deux on va faire le
troisième dans un mois et demi
les deux premiers s'appellent BP France
entreprise ils ont très bien marché on a
levé au total 400 millions
ils feront des rendements très élevés
très élevés parce que c'est des bons
millésimes voilà donc les il ne pourra
pas y avoir de l'inquiétude quelconque
ce seront de très beaux rendements
celui qu'on lance là est différent c'est
du primaire c'est de là sont du
secondaire donc du primaire on va lever
de l'argent
pour qu'il soit investi dans les années
qui viennent donc c'est des produits
plus longs donc on ne pense pas pouvoir
lever 200 millions c'est un peu plus
risqué on lèvera
50 à 100
le 55 ans que j'ai dépôt état et ben moi
je trouve qu'il est très bien le 55 ans
parce que je suis je suis arrivé dans ce
monde compliqué
dans un état de guerre totale entre
l'État et la caisse il faut se souvenir
de ce que c'était il y a 10 ans c'était
vraiment les attrides
or la seule solution pour que l'État et
la caisse travail correctement ensemble
c'est qu'il soit à 55 ans dès qu'il y en
a un qui domine l'autre c'est l'horreur
voilà alors c'est pas je dis pas ça pour
laisser entendre que je serai sans
contrôle parce que la vérité c'est qu'à
55 ans la caisse et l'État sont donc
quantité de comité interne de BPI France
tous les investissements supérieurs à 50
millions d'euros c'est l'état et la
caisse qui qui tamponne ils ont un droit
de veto donc ils sont très très présent
dans la gestion mais je note que par
rapport à au côté presque alors bon je
vais pas utiliser l'objectif mais je je
j'ai une opinion enfin disons excessif
des conflits de l'époque entre la caisse
et l'État qui était qui était qu'elle
est au détriment des intérêts du pays
honnêtement et le 55 ans a complètement
pacifié la relation
voilà je le prends comme une bonne
nouvelle par conséquent et puis pour
terminer la question Gérard Longuet
donc est-ce qu'on est ce qu'on est
finalement sinequanone et donc guide
keeper comme on dit en anglais
alors je
ne pense pas je ne pense pas on pense
pas c'est-à-dire que il est vrai que ça
rassure tout le monde qu'on soit là
il est vrai que tout le monde est bien
content qu'on soit dans les poules
mais il y a des jeux concurrentiels
c'est à dire que quand vous avez un pool
sur une PME et vous avez une banque x
privé
qui sait qu'elle va pas pouvoir faire le
crédit tout seul elle préfère parfois
appeler la BPI plutôt que d'appeler une
autre banque y pour la faire rentrer
dans le compte
voilà parce que la banque y elle est
menaçante au sens où elle peut demander
à gérer les flux alors que nous ne
gèrerons jamais les flux nous ne gérons
pas les comptes
donc ça peut jouer ça mais de là dire
que si on n'est pas là le crédit se fait
pas honnêtement je ne pense pas
dans les investissements en fond de fond
il est vrai qu'un certain nombre de
fonds se sont habitués à ce que ce soit
mes pays France qui fassent toutes les
dieux du Legends c'est tellement plus
simple
et donc et donc et donc et donc nous
luttons contre ça
par exemple en décidant parfois de ne
pas faire le premier pas et on attend de
voir si le marché privé s'organise et à
ce moment-là on vient parce que je ne
veux pas que le marché s'habitue c'est
vrai qu'on a la plus grosse équipe la
plus professionnelle en fond de fond
donc ça serait tellement simple
mais je veux pas que le marché se mette
à par ailleurs très bien rémunéré pour
sa prestation comme vous le savez
dans le fond dans le Private équity se
mettre à penser comme ça voilà ce que je
peux répondre à la question de
la question du genre Longuet peut le
confirmer il y avait aussi peut-être la
question quand même de la responsabilité
que l'on a une fois qu'on est dedans
c'est à dire si BPI ne suit pas ne
continue pas enfin le rôle qui peut
avoir comme finalement
des incitatif pour les autres voyez ce
que je veux une espèce de responsabilité
à rester dans l'entreprise après ou en
tout cas à se rendre compte que si on
voulait en sortir on crée on crée un
problème et c'est un peu sur
l'investissement mais ça c'est vrai
voilà sur les grands investissements des
collectivités par exemple lorsque vous
avez
la
Banque de Luxembourg là d'investissement
son nom la BU qui est là s'il avait eu
se retire ou ne met pas exactement ne
suis pas exactement le projet les autres
deviennent frileux bon voilà donc il
peut y avoir comme ce rôle c'est toute
la différence entre être sinequanone et
être rassurant
on est on est extrêmement rassurant
extrêmement rassurant et c'est dans un
marché qui est un marché assez
moutonnier où les gens peuvent tout d'un
coup cristalliser des positions
négatives c'est très utile
disons que ça rassure tout le monde
c'est bien merci Monsieur le Directeur
général
nous nous restons tout cela vous le
savez pour pour le vote merci